tick tock everyone's favorite app
the more i think about i'm like well at
least it's better than twitter right
let's check out some great tick tocks
absolutely the best
see some of them are funny i mean i know
it's just a random [ __ ] video but
step aside rumba this isn't your
business this is none of your business
hello casually did that i don't know
animals crack me up
just because animals are just themselves
right there's no
you know there's no pretense that's why
it's funny no this isn't abroad it's
cornwall
i've been there expectation
i love these it's so funny because it's
so
true if you lived in uk for a while it's
just like
yeah it's always kind of just gray all
the time man
i don't know how i guess the tick tock
algorithm understands me and i get a lot
of these and they crack me the [ __ ] up
sorry michelle keller talking about
scooby doo offered
so much more than every other cartoon it
was so ahead of its time
true story they they did it was hard to
figure it out and it wasn't
gender specific it wasn't a boy's
cartoon or a girl's cartoon or any of
those things
it was a talking dog you know what i
mean
you know bro it's like it's talking dog
what do you want me to say
what's the point of this interview it
was a talking dog
yeah yeah i don't care magnetized floor
used in fell
pressed right against him but what's a
magnet i don't get what
i get that this is like a fun little
fact and i'm sure i'll i'll
say it before i get the chance watching
the movie again with someone else
hey you know why the ring fell
really like it felt pretty it looked
pretty heavy there huh
you know how they you know how they did
that oh they probably use magnets or
something
no i don't know there's something about
just completely pointless information
that just gets me man
did you ever wonder where would you end
up if you take a tunnel through the
earth
this new object okay so i actually saved
this because i wanted to check it
reality tool by google just lets you do
that
and the tool is called flume
gotta download flume we're downloading
flume now
blooming it up what's underneath us is
it china like they always said
it's a [ __ ] lie there's no app called
flume i've been bamboozled
[ __ ] you flume suck my dick tick tock
violence in canada graphic 18 plus oh
boy
hope i don't get oh no
gently puts it down and skates away
[ __ ] you canada they go hard in canada
you don't mess around with
canadians damn doom
cool it mister in front of the children
what is wrong with you you savage
okay yeah i showed up in my own face
what are you going to do with that
alcohol david
what do you do with that whiskey
yeah you slime ball you sleeze ball that
actually looks insane in person
yeah get david dobrik the [ __ ] out of my
feet what does he do with money bags
i'm gonna give it away to my fans
because i love my friends so much it's a
giveaway
what color do you see okay uh there's
many colors
there take a look at this square what
color is it
what if i told you that it was a red
square you'd likely be a little confused
and
you might even argue telling me that it
is not red it is naughty colored
it's multicolored what do you say if i
then said well i'll prove it to you
and then proceeded to point to only the
examples of red spots in the picture
would that convince you no it would not
convince me
those are red squares you're dumb [ __ ]
you asked what the color of the square
is of course not
you challenge that flawed thinking and
points
but how often do you look back at
moments in your life when you felt down
or you couldn't cope
and then generalize those moments into a
statement about your whole life for
example
only bad stuff happens to me rather than
seeing the huge variety of different
experiences hey don't turn it into some
positive psychology
way of thinking all right i want to know
why the [ __ ] that cut that square is red
that was the point you know you don't
trick me into something making me feel
good about myself or my
male well mental well-being get out of
here thoughts that you
know so if you're telling stories about
yourself that aren't helpful
ask yourself is this story actually true
or am i only focusing on those moments
that feed this story
and ignoring the wonderful bright colors
that appear in the other places in my
life
get out skid out skid out get out of
here
it's red it's not red it's it's a
rainbow square [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[Music]
[Laughter]
some tick tocks are genuinely so
funny
oh okay this is cool so you know i did
this play through this game we call it
called before your eyes
and actually found it through a
tick-tock isn't that crazy
i would never have found it otherwise
[Music]
i was like oh that sounds cool you use
your blinking and you're crying
love that i'm officially not a tick-tock
hater just because of this one tick-tock
that helped me find a cool game
why are chinese no good at cricket why
are the chinese no good at cricket
because they eat all the [ __ ] bats
oh they love that joke yeah
[Laughter]
sort of thing with india and china that
i don't know about that if so that makes
it funnier
but i'm too impatient to wait for the
ice to melt
well that hurt but i can still walk so
while i'm here again
disoriented and the ice feels extra
slippery for some reason jumping on my
board doesn't feel quite the same this
time as i must have hit my head pretty
hard
everything just feels like it's spinning
and spinning and spinning and wait a
minute where am i i'm so confused
there are some cool thick thoughts i my
mind is changing slowly i'm opening up
i like it okay so this is a british like
uh
postman delivery notice left under great
bin
[Music]
thank you postman i would never have
found it otherwise
i like how this has been reposted like
what four times look at this
thank you for specifying postman would
you buy this phone for two thousand five
hundred dollars hey look
who would spend that much on a cellphone
this is the samsung galaxy z fold two
pretty cool right so would you buy it
okay now dumbest idea ever i bought two
of them
one for me and one for marzia
[Music]
why why do people have to add themselves
into these [ __ ]
whatever like this is fine on its own
you don't need your stupid face there
going
perspective how does it work man
what the [ __ ] dude it's stuff like this
that makes tick tock so cringy maybe
a trick that you need to start using
today to organize
better you can unscrew the lid and put
i can start using that today thank you
yeah what the [ __ ] would you do that
i'm glad at least some tick targets are
calling out how [ __ ] dumb they
did it that's hilarious top dogs that
can kill you quickly
[Music]
millionaires within seconds
george georgie two to three business day
mate
i get the job done i get better get
cracking mate just scared of shiv man
okay so apparently if you take chapstick
and put it on the bottom of a cap
and then put that cap on something made
of glass the suction will make it
shatter but i don't believe it so
let's try it okay so they didn't show
the result
thank you it just ends there oh okay i
wonder what happened it's not like we
can see that you just
pulled it out [ __ ] you just take talk
god i hate some of that
youtubers that didn't let money change
them part one oh
you guys shouldn't have done that mr
peace deserves it for sure
am i where am i in there you forgot to
put me
inside best life hack ever ever
ever put your keynote for a shopping
trolley
use your door key just use your door key
bro and if it gets stuck
you won't be able to go home but at
least you got your
that's such a shitty life hack plus you
would have to take it off your key chain
that's more effort than just
going up and asking for a pound get out
of here
get out of here it's not the best life
hack ever
making unusual watches so you don't have
to wear boring ones
yeah they look sick how do you tell time
on these
seriously how what hey man uh what
let's see how i watch what's the time uh
it's
let's see the sun is in the
just give me a moment just give me more
i got this i almost got this
let's see here let me just like what
it's four four ten okay i got that one
right no the moon disappears what
okay it's uh which one is which though
which one take oh my god there
i get it it's cool and yeah yeah they're
really cool but
i have to tell the time on that thing
this is why we can't get it
back in the bag another completely
unnecessary woman that decides to film
herself
for no reason
just let the tick tock be okay you don't
have to add yourself i understand it's
tempting
did you know that banging on these
american airlines try to save money by
removing a single olive from their meals
they removed the said olive from every
single first class meal
and in total this helped them save
around forty thousand dollars
i didn't know that now i completely
understand the entire airline
industry and whether they're trying to
skip down on it
god damn it this is where it all went
down in the 1990s
those american airlines it starts with
an olive
this is why you should never budge to
anyone just trying to be like it's just
olive bro look where we are with
airlines now
it's just an olive man don't worry about
it
are you crying over an olive it's not
the olive it's what it represents for
the future
who out here spending 390 000 on
an aliexpress pool like is there a
market for this
who's buying this like is it a scam but
for that's literally like spongebob this
is from like the nickelodeon like water
yes it's a scam it's a scam you've been
scammed
you've been scammed out of the water
park [ __ ] i ordered a water park and i
got
scammed yeah companies probably
manufactured these [ __ ] things i
don't know what to tell you
isn't that scam i don't get it have you
ever been to a water park
then yes yes there is a market for it
what the [ __ ]
hell yeah i'll buy it 320 hell yeah give
me that give me that now
very good this has been tick tock with
me pewdiepie if you enjoy episode
feel free to hit the like button it
helps me out so much
you wouldn't believe thank you and the
breakfast
oh oh what it was spins